je m'appelle Yann Swan et cet homme est
mon prisonnier
vous êtes robicola
chasseur de prime
j'ai travaillé longtemps avec Yann c'est
pas fait que des amis
il paraît qu'il traquait un très gros
poisson êtes-vous dangereux
professionnel
parce que j'ai déjà assez d'amis comme
ça
le crack de la coke le plus gros
narcotrafiquant du minouest on va
exploiter les enfer la plateforme
mondiale de la dope
à partir de maintenant chacun pourra y
réaliser ses rêves
est un tueur de sang-froid ni au cartel
un dernier conseil à ta place je
quitterai cette île définitivement on y
va
on s'y fait
il est très influent sur cette île ne
doutez jamais de moi
tu crois qu'il va se noyer
est-ce que vous attendez qu'il neige
j'ai tout sauf de la chance
tu es trop con pour mourir tu m'as couru
après pendant 10 ans je suis un peu
maniaque